[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver dans
le 7-8 loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
dans les départements et on commence au
but avec le sommaire de ce numéro
ce dimanche voisins le bretonneux
accueillera le premier championnat
interclubs de sabre laser au programme
des combats bien sûr mais aussi des jeux
star wars et des initiations
le président de l'académie de sabre
laser sera avec nous pour nous dévoiler
le programme les arts visuels à
l'honneur à guyancourt pour sa deuxième
édition le concours art à l'an regroupe
plus de 80 artistes sélectionnés par un
jury et les visiteurs sont invités à
participer pour le prix du public fêter
la nature à saint quentin en yvelines
plusieurs animations sont proposées sur
le territoire notamment une visite
ludique au coeur de la réserve naturelle
50 ans en usine
le point avec mélanie poquet sur les
rendez-vous junior à ne pas manquer et
on commence par une pièce de théâtre
musical à découvrir sur les planches du
théâtre
alphonse daudet à coignières
professionnels et amateurs se retrouvent
pour un même spectacle une croisière de
ouf 25 comédiens danseurs et chanteurs
nous font vivre cette comédie déjantée
du 16 au 20 mai françois guillon le
metteur en scène de la pièce nous a
parlé de ses inspirations
on a pris le parti de s'inspirer de
faire une parodie un petit peu de la
croisière s'amuse
et puis de dons que ce sont des
histoires qui s'entremêlent
il va retrouver les personnages de
labiche les personnages de monsieur
perrichon on va retrouver également les
personnages du malade imaginaire de
molière on va retrouver un don juan de
molière on va retrouver des personnages
de anouilh et tout ça ça va être entre
mêlée est entrecoupé de chansons de
danser pour faire 1
un grand divertissement qui est très
rafraîchissant
[Musique]
les combats de sabre laser de star wars
vous ont toujours fasciné et pourquoi
pas assister un championnat de sabre
laser c'est le dimanche 14 mai pardon à
voisins le bretonneux
le premier championnat interclubs
organisée par l'académie de sabre laser
de la ville avec nous son président
cédric giroux bonjour alors je le disais
ce dimanche ce championnat qui aura lieu
au centre sportif les pyramides en quoi
ça consiste qui va s'affronter alors
plusieurs catégories qui vont
s'affronter des enfants comme des
adultes
l'académie en fête propose plusieurs
façons de pratiquer le sabre laser qui
avait un petit peu mais la discipline à
la mode en ce moment on a basé notre
programme sur un bon système américain
qui s'appelle terra prix avec une partie
technique très développé donc du coup le
matin on va voir ce qu'on appelle des
d'humour un petit peu comme des kata
karaté dompter les gens vont présenter
une forme qui est la forme qu'on appelle
le chichon donc les enfants comme les
adultes
après on va voir des combats
chorégraphiés l'aller qu'on va
chorégraphié c'est un petit peu comme
une compétition au patinage artistique
les journaux font un petit peu leurs
chorégraphies de combat et on a imposé
certains mouvements début d'année qu'ils
vont devoir en fait replacé de danse qui
servira de critères de jugement fait
pour l'ensemble des compétitions et
l'après midi on aura des compétitions en
duel et en équipe avec ce qu'on appelle
un sport à la touche c'est dire qu'en
fait ils font toucher son partenaire
avec le sabre laser
chaque zone comme tout jeu rapportent
plus ou moins deux points c'est 15
points gagnés en trois minutes
donc la même chose des enfants comme les
adultes vont pouvoir se rencontrer
la particularité c'est la compétition en
équipe qui est un petit peu plus
rigolote tourner vers le roleplay un
petit peu le grandeur nature où on
dépense des pointes pour crever son
équipe et on a des pouvoirs de la force
pour utiliser avec des équipes non
virtuel un peu spéciaux donc ça amène un
côté ludique
en plus de la partie martial qu'on va
proposer et on a vu un petit peu
quelques images là qui sont casting
alors le combat au sabre laser qu'est ce
que c'est il ya plusieurs disciplines ça
mélange plusieurs disciplines oui c'est
ça
à l'origine tels que george michael
avait pensé quand il a créé son univers
c'était très inspiré du king kendo donc
plutôt escrime japonaise mais en fait
qu'on voit maintenant la quantification
via les romans les jeux informatiques
tout ce qu'il ya autour de cet
univers-là saml on va effectivement de
l'escrim japonaise
les scream on va dire de cape et d'épée
entre guillemets et puis également du
kung fu ça peut être également de la
canne de combat française essar group
vraiment plusieurs façons de pratiquer
en sachant que la pratique du sabre
laser à son identité et on veut pas
pratiqué comme une autre discipline
parce qu'on serait trop ainsi mêlé à ça
donc le système terra prix ont fait que
voilà on a cette identité visuelle avec
des formes différentes des façons de
combattre différent parce qu'il ya le
sabre laser seule mais ô dieu la
possibilité aussi travaillé de sabre
laser le double sabre laser 22 des armes
un petit peu référence sur les
différents univers qu'on connaît sur les
différents épisodes également exactement
et lors de cette journée il ya également
des animations et notamment des
initiations pour ceux qui voudraient
essayer c'est ça on voulait faire un
grand événement vraiment quelque chose
d'assez das est énorme entre guillemets
pour une première année
de création de l'académie donc la partie
sportive déroulera toute la journée y
aura un concours de cosplay d'après midi
pendant la journée les gens peuvent
participer à notre première convention
ludique la convention lui dit qu'elle
est dédié à l'univers de star wars avec
des jeux de plateau des jeux de
figurines il ya un magasin qui sera là
et qui présenteraient un tournoi de x
wing qui est le jeu référence pour les
petits combats avec les vaisseaux
spatiaux de star wars
donc les gens sont invités à participer
en sachant qu'il ya une grande tombola
les gens qui viennent leur ticket
d'entrée donnant il ya un billet de
tombola qui inclut on a plusieurs prix
dont un sabre laser de compétition qui
fait du son et la lumière qui composent
l'univers de star wars c'est encore
quelque chose qui fait rêver un même les
plus jeunes qu'est ce qui a motivé la
création de ce championnat
en fait quand on regarde en france il
existe de nombreuses années plein
d'associations sportives au club sportif
qui pratique dans un premier temps fait
la chorégraphie de combat au sabre laser
donc ça c'était quelque chose qui
existait depuis nombreuses années et
puis le combat sportif est arrivé nous
on a voulu vraiment faire en sorte que
le combat sportif soit le plus
sécuritaire possible au niveau des
pratiquants donc on considère comme un
art martial on apprend à maîtriser
larmes et du coup ça amène des choses
contrôle et honni
au niveau des pratiquants lors des
combats on voulait donner une dynamique
de groupe en fait avec le programme
commun tp à la sur laquelle ou en fait
je suis représentant en france
via l'académie américaine on propose au
club en fait de travailler sur ce
programme technique et du coup avec
notre système de compétition qui est une
création française
ça nous permet de nous regrouper et de
pouvoir la développer une dynamique de
groupe qui n'existe pas encore vraiment
en france et un dernier petit mot très
rapidement pour les jeunes padawans qui
aimerait vous rejoindre et suivre des
cours alors comment ça se passe alors on
les accueille pour le moins
voisins-le-bretonneux uniquement ce
qu'on apprend à développer d'autres
sections sportives c'est le samedi
nos gens qui est au tennis club de
voisins-le-bretonneux on a deux sections
les 8 10 ans et les 11 14 à partir de 15
ans considèrent qu'ils sont comme des
adultes on les prend dans le cours
adultes tous les liens sont de toute
façon sur le site internet
c'est internet qui s'affichent au bas de
l'écran tout cas merci beaucoup cédric
giroud pour toutes ces précisions
et on le rappelle le championnat se
déroule dimanche 14 mai au centre
sportif les pyramides tout le programme
de cette journée est à retrouver sur le
site internet de l'académie également
merci beaucoup c'est drissi camille et
guyancourt mais les artistes à l'honneur
jusqu'au 28 mai la nouvelle édition
d'art talent concours d'arts visuels
présente une sélection d'oeuvres de
différentes techniques
rencontre avec deux artistes sur les
images de nicolas landry
peintures sculptures ou des seins des
dizaines de techniques pour une même
exposition guyancourt a rassemblé plus
de 80 artistes
une manière de célébrer la diversité des
arts visuels
parmi les travaux exposés ceux de daniel
convenant ce peintre de versailles créé
ses toiles avec du bitume
c'est un noir profond est contente qu'on
peut diluer à l'infini et je drague
comme une à croix je travaille après une
après une période de réflexion de plus
ou moins long ça peut être géré quelques
têtes le jour ou une semaine les
tableaux de daniel convenant font partie
des oeuvres sélectionnées par un jury de
professionnels claude champy est invité
d'honneur de cette deuxième édition
d'art talent l'artiste exposé dans le
monde entier et a reçu de nombreux prix
son travail se tournent plutôt vers le
minéral
un monde où le fâche travail la
porcelaine aussi ma phase est la même
pour moi c'est la même chose c'est les
mêmes températures de cuisson seul et je
cherche à raconter à faire parler du
jour là la matière dont il ya toujours
une volonté peut-être à peu prétentieuse
mais de clash mick bien mon boulot
si ça peut aider éclosion justement au
seul le soleil peut être la lave
samedi 13 mère nathalie et d'écriture
artistique animé par l'un des membres du
jury est proposé aux visiteurs
ils peuvent également participer au prix
du public en votant pour l'oeuvre de
leur choix rendez-vous junior très vert
aujourd'hui mélanie poker va nous parler
de plusieurs rendez vous autour de la
nature et de l'environnement bonjour
mélanie bonjour cali alors pour notre
premier rendez vous ont pas à la réserve
naturelle de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
elle participe le 20 mai à la fête de la
nature alors c'est un rendez vous
national qui lui et a lieu du 17 au 21
mai et cette année c'est une grande fête
de la nature qui est proposée par les
équipes
laval la balade va dépasser la réserve
puisque vous pourrez faire le tour de
l'étang et découvrir sa faune et sa
flore le printemps les couleurs voilà du
paysage sont simplement magnifique vous
avez de jolies fleurs aussi à observer
et chez les oiseaux vous avez les jeunes
qui sont nés
donc vous avez l'occasion de voir le
nourrissage des adultes auprès des
jeunes c'est souvent pour les enfants
notamment un spectacle assez sympathique
alors le parcours fait neuf kilomètres
peut paraître assez long c'est pour tout
le monde oui parce qu'en fait c'est une
balade tranquille qui s'adresse aux
enfants est des neuf ans il faut quand
même avoir à l'habitude de marcher des
pauses vont être faites pour admirer les
oiseaux découvrir les plantes et surtout
le thème de cette année est très adapté
aux enfants puisqu'ils vont découvrir
les les super pouvoirs de la nature il
faut juste penser à vous inscrire au
numéro qui va s'afficher en bas de
l'écran vous prévoyez aussi votre
pique-niqué vos chaussures de marche et
les chaussures les chaussures les
jumelles par banque vous seront prêtés
et le second
et vous lui s'éteint voisins le
bretonneux et c'est une première pour la
commune c'est une première et c'est sur
une longue durée puisqu'il s'agit de la
toute première semaine autour du
développement durable et au sens large
donc il y à l'environnement bien sûr
mais aussi les loisirs la santé et le
bien-être alors pour les grands il ya
des conférences d'information la
projection d'un film demain et des
ateliers autour de la sophrologie et de
la méditation
bien sûr les enfants ne sont pas oubliés
écoute réécouter katrina adjointe au
maire à l'environnement qui a plusieurs
activités du style confection de refuges
à insectes les l'après midi atelier
jardinage ils pourront planter faire des
ports faire dd des hôtels à insectes
voyez donc ils vont pouvoir faire
plusieurs types d'activités alors pour
l'après midi jardinage et il est
possible d'y venir des des conseillers
ne peut pas tout y est dans la terre
donc des quatre ans je dirais que c'est
faisable dès qu'on tient sur ses jambes
et qu'on sait faire un petit peu quelque
chose de ses mains
alors pour les premiers rendez-vous
proposé le rendez-vous lui est donné le
dimanche 14 mai au parc d'avroy dubois
et pour découvrir le reste du programme
direction des sites internet de la
commune merci beaucoup mais là nous
avoir présenté ces événements et
puisqu'on parle de nature justement
l'association jardins passions partage
organise une après midi de troc
l'objectif apporter des livres ou des
plantes et les échanger avec les autres
participants
l'événement se déroule de 14h à 16h
samedi 13 mai à la maison de quartier
théodore monod de guyancourt hank de
faux la présidente de l'association nous
en dit plus sur le principe de cette
journée vous pouvez venir avec des
beauty voitures ou des plantes ou des
livres et après si vous voulez vous
poser sur la table
puis après je vous connais ce que vous
voulez après c'est pas parce que vous
donnez un livre que vous devez prendre
votre livre surtout au mois d'avril mai
et juin c'est la période où on a
beaucoup de verdure et c'est là qu'on a
des trous dans notre jardin parce que
des fois qu'on en a trop bon c'est pas
quoi faire au lieu de gt mais on fait
les changes on dort on donne plutôt
l'étape des champs c'est bien mais c'est
surtout quand on donne
et a rendez vous à noter dans nos
agendas vendredi prochain c'est
l'occasion de passer un moment convivial
avec ses voisins la fête des voisins un
événement traditionnel à plaisir et
l'encours pour développer les liens de
proximité pour savoir où se déroulent
les festivités renseignez vous auprès de
la mairie ou parlez-en à votre entourage
c'est la fin de ses études choisir je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous souhaite un excellent week end
[Musique]